[Musique]
alors spécialiste en jambes et en pied
robotique c'est un sujet qui joue la
corde peut faire un peu de science
fiction lancement probablement que
plusieurs d'entre vous avaient en tête
des robots marcheurs comme si trois purs
ou encore de terminator je devoir
malheureusement vous détromper parce que
dans le cas de mon projet c'est au
bonheur je n'y prends simon permettez
l'expression à contre-pied parce que
j'essaie de réduire au maximum le nombre
de moteurs dans le but d'économiser
industrie ce principe de réduction du
nombre de moteurs
l'exemple le plus visuelle que je
connaisse et celui du doigt humain comme
l'index par exemple c'est la capacité
étonnante de diviser l'action d'un seul
moteur lucide un seul muscles en fait en
deux mouvements distincts
je m'explique considérer la deuxième et
la troisième phalange vous allez
remarquer qu'il est impossible de les
bouger indépendamment
lorsqu'on ferme doit l'action du muscle
est divisée dans une proportion que ne
contrôle pas 50 50 entre ces deux
mouvements
on peut dire en fait une des phalanges
sont sur un pied d'égalité
par contre si je bloque la phalange du
milieu et que j'active le muscle cette
proportion va changer maintenant c'est
uniquement la phalange dubout qui bouge
ce qui nous permet de proposer une tâche
complexe comme saisir un objet sans
savoir à contrôler indépendamment chacun
des petits mouvements qui la composent
on appelle ça le toits d'habitations
mécanique
naturellement ce principe a été utilisé
à de nombreuses surprises pour la
conception de main robotique c'est juste
souvent de succès commerciaux parce
qu'une réduction du nombre de moteurs
entraîne une réduction du temps des
capteurs entraîne une réduction du poids
et tout ça ça se traduit par un coût
plus faible
moi maintenant je sais de transférer ses
avantages à la conception de jambes et
de pâtes robotique est d'ailleurs le
seul de ma thèse si vous prenez la
lettre c'est la conception de systèmes
mécaniques auto adaptatif pour la
locomotion
au jour le jour mon travail si beaucoup
de la géométrie laboratoire j'ai une
table avec un ordinateur aux femmes et
calcule les simulations mais surtout
j'ai eu notable sur laquelle je
construis prototype en collaboration
avec une stagiaire
parce qu'il est important de savoir dans
ce projet on est plusieurs à mettre la
main à la pâte
le meilleur mécanisme juste maintenant
est capable de diviser l'action d'un
seul moteur en deux mouvements distincts
le premier de soucis propus la pâte vers
l'avant à la recherche de nouvelles
appui alors que le second permet de
lever la pâte
le résultat si l'extrême de la pâte
fonce dans quelque chose comme un
obstacle
la proportion dans la caisse du
mouvement sont générés va changer ce que
vous mettre à la patte de glisser le nom
de l'obstacle
or éventuellement le surmonter dit comme
ça ça parlait de grand chose mais on est
les seuls au monde à obtenir un tel
résultat sans nécessiter de capteurs de
caméras ou domaine des moteurs
additionnel au final je travaille
d'arrache-pied en fait on peut même dire
que j'ai fait des pieds et des mains
pour qu'un jour mes robes aux marcheurs
tout terrain soit utilisé dans des
applications comme l'exploration
spatiale ou la recherche de survivants
après une catastrophe aussi des
applications plus d'art à terre comme la
construction d'orthez par exemple les
roues du futur comme c3po où il termina
tard est bien certain de pied ferme
parce que j'offre une alternative peut
s'avérer plus simple peut s'avérer moins
coûteuse c'est clair que sur le marché
pourrait voir un demande pour un produit
comme ça le plus important à cette
étape-ci du projet c'est encore de
rester les deux pieds sur terre merci
beaucoup